-I know everybody sits there,
but it would be cool
if I did this right here.
[ Laughter, cheering,
and applause ]
-Yeah, that could be the new --
-Too much?
-No, we can do it
that way as well.
It's more therapy that way.
-I'll go over here.
-But you look like a stud.
You look fantastic, by the way.
-Oh!
You know what?
-Always good to see you, J.B.
-You know, I love fashion
and I love looking good
all the time, Jimmy.
-I know. You do.
-I love it.
I think it's a lost art.
-Fashion?
-Fashion! Ohh!
-Yeah.
Let me just say something.
I've known you for a long time.
You were a writer on "SNL."
Very, very funny,
always nice to me.
But I remember you liked comics
and you like comic books.
This is when like
-Ooh!
-no one was really --
I don't --
But you liked comic books
and would talk about it
in pitch ideas and...
-Mm.
-...now, you're in the
last two "Spider-Man."
-[ Laughs ]
-You're in like the biggest
movie of all time.
[ Cheering and applause ]
-It is absolutely...
-You did it!
-...absolutely a blessing, man.
You know what I did for it?
You know what?
I sat in the audience watching
an Avengers movie and I told
my wife, I said, "Baby" --
I told my wife, Shah --
I said, "Baby,
I would love to be in the
Marvel Universe, one day"
And, next thing you know,
I get a phone call
and I'm doing an Audi commercial
with Tom Holland,
which was one of the sponsors
of "Far From Home," right?
And it worked out great.
We had a great time.
You know, we connected.
We laughed at the commercial.
Next thing you know,
a few months later,
they give me a call
for the movie.
And then, of course,
they brought my character back
for "No Way Home."
This is great!
-Mr. Dell.
[ Cheering and applause ]
-How about this?
-[ Laughs ]
-How about this? How about this?
I think you do a Mr. Dell
spinoff.
-Oh, oh, oh.
[ Cheering and applause ]
Jimmy.
Jimmy, don't start nothing, man.
You know I love to be --
-I'm going to start something.
-You know I love comic books.
I would love to be --
The first thing I did,
when they called me
about doing "Spider-Man,"
the first thing you ask,
if Marvel calls you
about anything is,
"What are my powers?"
-Yes, of course.
[ Laughter ]
-See? And they told me
I was a teacher,
so I had the power of knowledge.
But it's okay.
[ Laughter and applause ]
-That's good.
-But you know I love me
some superheroes, man.
I got a lot of ideas
for my own characters, you know.
Now, I would love
to be a character that flies,
but I'm a little scared
of heights, so,
[ Laughter ]
I would fly two feet
off the ground.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Just two feet, you know.
-Float or parallel?
-Oh, no, just --
Now, that's a good question.
If you float like this,
it's like you're riding
a Segway, you know what I mean?
Like this, like this.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah.
-That ain't bad.
-That's not bad.
-But I want to fly.
I want to be able to do this
to people, say hi.
And people can touch you, too.
They say, "Hey, hey,
good job," see?
-Yeah.
[ Laughter and applause ]
You know?
You can go to Starbucks.
-Yeah.
-You can fly by a Starbucks,
you know?
Drive-throughs, you know?
[ Laughter ]
-Oh, you're only two feet
off the ground.
-If I'm two feet off the ground,
I got to follow
all the traffic rules.
[ Laughter ]
I can't just go
through a red light.
I see the light.
I can't just go through it.
I'd cause an accident.
-Yeah.
How about this?
What if you're a villain?
What if you came out
as a villain?
-Oh, oh, well, the villain.
Oh, I would be a character
called Sucker Punch.
[ Laughter and applause ]
And he has the gift of gab.
He'll talk to you.
Next thing,
you get your guard down
a little bit
and he'll punch you in the face.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Come on, man.
He's a great hero.
-Sucker --
-Sucker Punch.
I got another guy.
Hey, how about this hero?
It's a guy named What I Say?
[ Laughter ]
What I Say?
He has the ability to go back
seven seconds, resolve an issue,
you know what I mean?
Change his mind, then come back
to the present, see?
[ Cheering and applause ]
He wins every argument.
He go back seven seconds,
and then come back.
-[ Laughs ]
-"What I say?"
-"I'll be right back."
Go back.
[ Laughter and applause ]
[ Slapping desk ]
Aaaah!
-J.B., I got to tell you, man,
-Whoo!
-I was looking for a laugh
the other night, man, and I go,
"Man, I forgot that 'Curb'
just wrapped the 11th season."
"Curb Your Enthusiasm,"
it's as funny as always.
You were the funniest man
on television.
-Oh, man, I appreciate it.
-You were unbelievable, man.
It was a great season.
You are just --
You and Larry, Larry David.
It's just so fun to watch.
I wish it was like
three hours long.
-I know, man.
-Do you crack him up?
-You know what?
As a comedian,
we have great intentions
for our audience,
but we have bad intentions.
We want you to wet your pants.
We want you to do
all these things.
When I'm performing with Larry,
I don't break.
I don't break at all.
I give him the line.
And my back of my mind is,
in back of my brain,
I'm thinking,
"I'm going to make a snot bubble
come out his nose."
[ Laughter and applause ]
That's my motivation.
I want to see a snot bubble.
-Come out of Larry David's nose.
Want when people hold
their laughter in
and you see them cracking
a little bit --
Because you can tell Larry's
cracking because his right
or left side of his mouth
goes like this.
"Ahh!
[ Laughter ]
[ Mumbling ]"
He does that a little bit.
-That's him breaking.
-"Ahh!"
-"Ahhh!"
-He's trying to hold it in.
-[ Laughs ]
-But, yes,
it was an amazing process, man.
Another thing that happened
with that --
I'm a seed planter, man.
I truly believe that, somehow,
the universe works with you
in some way, man.
When you work hard
and you put time into it, man,
and you love what you love --
You know, my wife told me
I was going to be
on "Curb Your Enthusiasm."
We would watch it.
We were actually working
together at "SNL" and we would
watch "Curb," of course.
We'd come in,
we'd talk about "Curb"
in the writers' room.
And I told my wife -- We were
watching the show one night.
I said, "Baby, I would love
to be on this show, one day."
And she said, "You're going
to be on that show, one day,
because I could see you
and Larry together.
You're both lanky as hell.
[ Laughter ]
I can see you guys just working
together and laughing
and doing something together."
And, next thing you know, man,
I come into L.A.
for a friend's memorial service,
for one day.
This is after I didn't get
renewed by "SNL"
my fourth season.
So I went to L.A.
for one day, man,
and my buddy --
The Roots know my buddy,
you know, Oji Pierce.
He did, "This Is How We Do It."
"This Is How We Do It."
And I went in town for him
and, man,
My agent sent me
to "Curb Your Enthusiasm"
for an audition, man,
and I walked in that room.
Larry was standing
in the middle of the room.
You know, I have this thing I do
where I come in the room
as the character.
I never go in a room as J.B.
and then turn the character on
because I feel like
there's a disconnect.
-Wow.
-I come into --
I like to get the room.
I like to come in there and get
your attention immediately.
So I came in as Leon,
had my little hand right here
looking around the room,
doing my little Leon thing.
Larry's standing
in the middle of the room.
They said, "Okay. You're gonna
improvise with Larry."
I said, "Okay. Cool."
And this is a character.
It's not me speaking.
But I walked in the room.
I said, "Okay, Larry.
Let's do this.
We're gonna improvise, right?
Anything could happen.
I might -- I might slap you
in the face. I don't know."
[ Laughter ]
And Larry looked
at the producers like...
-Who's this guy?
-"Do we need to call security
on this dude?"
But -- But that was --
And we hit it off right away.
He laughed.
We laughed through
the whole audition process.
We had a great time.
And first day -- Quickly.
First day on the job, he said
it felt as though we'd been
working together for years.
-Is that right?
-Yeah, because I truly believe
somehow, I said, we have.
I said we have.
-Yeah.
-This idea came up
two years ago,
somewhere two years ago.
And that's the fun thing about,
you know,
being an actor and our journey.
We have no idea
where we're going to end up at.
We worked together at "SNL."
-Never knew that we would --
-All younger faces, you know?
-Yeah, exactly. Yeah.
Younger face.
-You didn't wear a suit.
You wore T-shirts all the time.
-Exactly. Yeah, of course.
That's right.
-And I believe you might have
wore shorts in the wintertime.
I'm not sure.
But anyway --
You were just
a young, wild dude.
Look at you. Professional.
Suit, tie every night.
Doing an amazing show like this.
This is how
the journey goes, man.
-Yeah, I'll tell you
what's great, too, is that
I think the secret sauce
is we're very lucky.
We have great wives.
-We have great wives, man. Yes.
-That's the secret sauce.
She's beautiful.
-She is absolutely gorgeous,
man, and so supportive, man.
I cannot ask
for anything more, man.
-She's the coolest.
-You know, health, love,
happiness, man.
It all goes together, man.
And some amazing fans, man.
-That's exactly right.
-And I told you --
-They're the ones.
-I told you about the time
I met --
I find out people
all the time are my fans.
I had no idea.
-Who's a fan
that you didn't have an idea?
-I was in a restaurant,
one my favorite restaurants
called Craig's in L.A.
-Yeah.
-And my wife and I
are having dinner.
Felt a little tap
on my shoulder.
And I said, "Uh-oh."
And this is pre-COVID,
so I turned around.
I was like, "Okay."
-Yeah, 'cause now you wouldn't.
"Who's tapping me?"
-"Give me a minute."
Put my mask back on.
And someone said...
"Hi. We work --
We work for Mick Jagger."
I said, "Oh, wow.
I love Mick Jagger."
"He's a huge fan
of 'Curb Your Enthusiasm.'
And he loves you."
I said, "What?!
I love Mick Jagger!"
I said, "What?!"
"He's on tour right now
in Ireland.
You know what? You want to --
You know what? You know what?
You want to surprise him?
You want to surprise him
and go to Ireland to a show?"
I said, "Oh, oh.
Don't make me do this.
"I've got -- I've got a show
tomorrow night in Albuquerque,
but I can call and cancel,
but I can't call and cancel."
They said Mick Jagger was a fan.
I was blown away, man,
because this dude
is the ultimate performer, man.
-It's Mick Jagger.
-It's Mick Jagger, man.
-He's the greatest performer.
And then he was in another city,
and I called his assistant,
and it was after my show.
It was like 12:30, 1:00
in the morning,
and I called the lady back.
She said,
"Call me after your show."
I called her after the show.
She said, "Oh, I'm sorry.
He's turned in for the evening."
Now, I can't see Mick Jagger
"turning in." He's so --
They say this man does six miles
every performance,
walking back --
prancing back and forth.
-Yeah.
-He does six miles!
You know how --
You know how much energy
you got to have to do
six miles every show?!
-Yes.
-Good gracious, man.
Hey. Give me a little bit.
Give me a little bit.
-Yeah, yeah.
-Come on. You...
♪♪
-He's, like, doing that --
Yeah.
♪♪
Then you gotta turn in.
-Oh, yeah!
-Alright!
♪♪
Oh, yeah!
Alright. Do --
J.B.! J.B.! J.B.!
So what did -- So what --
So what did --
What did Mick say
when you talked to him?
-I didn't talk to him.
I didn't get a chance
to talk to the man.
His assistant kept telling me...
She asked me if I would
love to fly to Ireland,
and I couldn't go to Ireland.
-You went to Albuquerque.
You got a gig.
You're a loyal dude. That's why.
But, Mick, if you're watching,
J.B. is looking to hang.
-I'm looking to hang, man.
-Let's make this happen.
-He would walk six miles.
We would walk six miles for you.
-I will walk six miles
for you, man.
I would love to meet you.
And I appreciate your assistant
who tried to make it work, man.
But, you know, we're both
working professionals.
I love you, Mick Jagger.
I love you, man.
Thank you for watching
"Curb Your Enthusiasm."
Thank you for supporting
J.B. Smoove and Leon.
-Thank you, Mick Jagger.
-I want to show everyone a clip.
Here's J.B. Smoove
and Larry David
in "Curb Your Enthusiasm."
Take a look at this.
[ Cheering and applause ]
-That's why Mary Ferguson
had to go.
-What are you gonna do?
You paid for the plane ticket.
It's got Mary Ferguson's
name on it. It's nonrefundable.
What are you gonna do? Eat it?
-No, I'm-a find me
another Mary Ferguson.
-[ Chuckles ]
What are you talking about?
-I'm gonna put an ad out.
I'm gonna get them all here.
I'm gonna audition a bunch
of Mary Fergusons,
find the one I like,
take her ass to Asia.
-What random Mary Ferguson
is gonna go to Asia
with some stranger
who's probably a sociopath?
-You're forgetting
one key thing here. Free.
Who wouldn't want to go
to Asia for free?
They'll take that chance waking
up dead for a free trip to Asia.
I promise you.
-I think you might
have something.
-J.B. Smoove.
Season 11
of "Curb Your Enthusiasm"
is streaming on HBO Max.
And "Spider-Man: No Way Home"
is in theaters now. J.B. Smoove!